hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and guess what today we're not
going to be talking about hunter hunter
so we're actually making good on the
tagline of the channel with this very
video and this time we are branching out
with a blind review of black clover and
a lot of people have been telling me to
either read or watch this for quite some
time now like we're talking years and
i've always kind of pushed it to the
side because whilst there were many many
people trying to convince me to get into
black clover there were an equal amount
of people telling me to stay far far
away from it and usually when there's
some kind of division of opinion i tend
to land on the more critical side after
experiencing the series so why
even bother starting it yeah but at the
same time that is no way to live life so
here we are with a blind review of the
first arc of black clover which as far
as i'm aware is just called arc one
i couldn't find a name for it which was
disappointing and if it does have a name
then please do let me know down in the
comments below because i think this
is utter madness but whatever the case
if you're a fan of black clover a hater
of the series or even if you've never
heard of it then i do encourage you to
stay a while and listen because it's an
interesting little thing
also please do make sure to like this
video and or subscribe to the channel if
you want to see more stuff like this
looking at those metrics is the only
solid way i can judge that you guys want
to see more because i probably won't be
reading too many comments with your
spoilers so go ahead
and do the thing oh oh and just one more
thing before we begin i am reading the
black clover manga which at this stage
has presented me with
10 mighty chapters i might also watch
the anime afterwards but right now the
manga suits me
just fine and if you're seeing anime
clips or screenshots that's because i'm
not editing this video so say hi to
darker eye who is my editor for this one
they're kicking off with the premise
this
is a boy with a dream series in this
case we have our main child thing
asta who harbors the dream of one day
becoming the wizard king there's
multiple problems with this of course
one being that asta is but a poor lad
who lives in a village that nobody cares
about and probably even knows exists and
wizard kings are generally selected from
nobility in the nicer place of the world
or at least that's the impression we've
been given so he already has quite an
uphill battle
ahead but astor comes equipped with a
second detriment which is that he
is entirely unable to use magic and that
is important in black clover because
this realm which you can probably tell
by a title like
wizard king well everything is more or
less dictated entirely by
magic and if you have no magic well
you're pretty screwed son and i think
that premise is super easy to get on
board with you can call it a bit generic
i guess because i'm sure that most of us
can immediately think of a series with
the exact same framework you know the
talentless and or powerless young boy
who wants to be the best at the thing in
which they do in the world like deku
wanting to be a hero but not having a
quirk in my hero academia or naruto from
the acclaimed series
naruto the premise is generic for a
reason though because it is a tried and
tested formula i knew that i had seen
chapter one of black clover play out
several times before but i was still
pretty easily captured like when you see
just how much of a loser aster is and i
guess how
useful everyone else around him is it
makes me want to see asta succeed the
antithesis of which is the theme
of the very first chapter 99 of it
focuses on
asta failing over and over and over and
over and over again the most
embarrassing moment to which is when he
attends
i honestly forget what it's called but
some sort of like ceremony whereby 15
year olds get their grimoires grimoires
are important but of course none of the
funky books are attracted to astor
because well he
sucks however by the end of the chapter
the inevitable thing happens and what's
this a very unique and suspicious
grimoire appears at astor's moment of
need and saves him from first chapter
bad guy and that grimoire is marked with
a five-leaf clover
a black clover as well which i have been
told by the series that a literal devil
resides in that their fifth leaf and at
this point i don't quite know how true
that is but it made for one hell of an
image pun
intended and i'm quite interested by
this i tend to enjoy any time
our standard protagonists are saddled
with darker powers that they may
or may not need to struggle against as
much as any external enemy that really
doesn't solve much though because asta
is not granted magical powers through
his five-leaf grimoire he actually gets
something that i think is much more
better it allows him to wield anti-magic
in the form of a sword and yes i'm down
with this to contrast i think one of the
things that slightly disappointed me
about my hero academia is that i
really wanted to see deku become a hero
without a quirk maybe like a batman or
something so after he got the quirk i
was just a bit like
but i do very much like the black clover
solution thus far it doesn't incorporate
asta into the world of magic in fact it
goes to great lengths
to separate him from it and i like that
because it makes aster immediately more
interesting than any of the magic
wielders i've seen thus far although i
don't know surely anti-magic is
magic right even so nobody seems to
expect it and as such it's been
satisfying to see asta
cut down some fools but the other thing
chapter one does is establish a very
important relationship between asta and
yuno and this is actually what breaks
the first chapter shona mold a bit astor
and yuna were both abandoned as children
in the very same place on the very same
day no less and i
imagine they grew up sort of as brothers
and more recently as rivals because both
of them want to become the illustrious
wizard king and yuno is the polar
opposite of astor he is ridiculously
talented with the magics absurdly good
looking cool underall circumstances
and the parallels continue as i'm sure
they will for quite some time to come in
fact even when they eventually join
their wizard magic squadrons juno ends
up with the golden dawn squad who are
the bestest at the things and asta ends
up becoming part of the very looked down
upon black ball squad but there is a
distinct dynamic happening here astor is
being surrounded by darkness and devil
related things while stino appears to be
going in the opposite direction with a
more heavenly quality
in fact i'm going to try and call it now
you know is some kind of nobility right
i don't know it's just the way that this
series has gone to some great lengths to
state that nobles are just naturally far
more powerful and amazing by default and
it would further the juxtaposition
between yuno and astor you know astor
the poor village boy and you know the
long lost son of like a wizard king
or something then again there is also
another character who goes on to serve
that role opposite asta so who knows but
here's the thing about yuno in most
other stories this character
is a bit of a dick he's someone who the
author will encourage you to dislike at
least at first in order to get us more
on board with the protagonist but it's
not like that at all juno actually sees
potential in astor and respects him as a
rival due to their childhood so i like
him i like both of them and i hope that
they maintain this brotherhood
throughout the series but then again
they've got to come into conflict at
some point right
as for astor himself uh look he's kind
of a blank canvas to me i identify more
with his stereotype right now than i do
with
him as an actual person i like what he
represents but i have yet to see
anything that distinguishes him from the
vast sea of shonen protagonists except
that he
seems to yell he seems to yell a lot and
i really hope that isn't his crowning
unique character trait but beyond
chapter one we progress into the much
more interesting world of wizardry
asta and yuno are taking the magic
knight's entrance exam and as expected
yuno does amazingly in every single test
whilst asta sucks and makes an
embarrassment out of himself yet again
i mean in all but one area that area
being combat where asta gets to take
down bro
mcshitface and that feat along with
proudly claiming that he will be the
wizard king once again earns the
attention of the best character i've met
so far who is yami this man is
entertaining in every single panel he's
in and he is the leader of the black
bull squad the kind of outcast of the
magic knights the weird cousins nobody
wants to talk about let alone invite to
the family reunions but this
is perfect for astor because as an
outcast himself he is absolutely at home
with these
goofy weirdos before that though as
stated before yuna becomes indoctrinated
into the golden dawn squad who is led by
this guy who is not the wizard king but
pretty damn powerful nonetheless i don't
know maybe he is the wizard king i don't
know he's wearing a mask after all and
masks are suspicious
i get some real bad guy vibes from him
but whatever as such we now lose yuno
but gain a shocking amount of weird
people to fill his place
astor gets taken to the black bull's
housing facility i don't know if it has
a real name where quirky shenanigans use
and reminds me
very much of the guild introduction to
fairy tale and i'm going to be honest
i really don't remember too many of
these black bull
guys and gals apart from the half naked
boozy ho who actually throws up around
aster which is kind of funny oh and i
guess there's
magnus swing i think that's his name the
hot head character who allows astor to
display his true powers in anti-magic
and i guess i like him
enough characters like him are probably
better presented in anime form because
they get that vocal range to play with
and build a character through voice
alone i do however care much more about
noel i alluded to her before but she is
an interesting character
unlike astor who was a poor lad willing
to accept whatever came his way
noel is a lady of nobility great things
were expected of her but she had to
settle for the worst squad because they
turned out to be the only ones that
would take her so another great
dichotomy here between noel and astor
and i especially like the scene near the
end of the first arc where the two of
them were discussing money and it's just
so clear that noel doesn't understand
the value of money despite being
absolutely loaded with it meanwhile
asta's like well with this tiny amount i
could do this
this and this there's also a stark
contrast with magic of course
as a member of fine nobility noel is
well responsible for i think the
greatest magic power i've seen depicted
so far and her problem is she can't
control it which is something i greatly
enjoy
characters without flaws are incredibly
boring and noel's flaw is in perfect
balance to her
talent all the power in the world but
completely incapable of wielding it
properly that works for me and i guess
it works as a final counter to astor as
well because noel seems to be something
of an epitome of magic whilst asta is
the epitome of i guess
anti-magic it's very similar to the
aster unidynamic actually and i'm
wondering if noel and yuna might flip
roles in the future you know yuno
becomes corrupted by nobility resources
and power
and stuff whilst noel learns to be far
more humbled and appreciate the smaller
things in life
maybe maybe not maybe i shouldn't even
be trying to analyze things in mere 10
chapters in but here we are but to bring
this first arc to a climax we of course
had an
action-packed mage mission which weirdly
enough was probably my least favorite
part mostly because i didn't care about
the villains i don't even
remember his name something english but
ice guy had a fairly boring design and
he displayed very little in terms of
character except for
standing upright being stoic and being
loyal oh and also being quiet being very
quiet
and these kind of characters are the
absolute worst because it's a perfect
combination of sweet fa to latch onto
from my perspective there was no opening
anywhere to become invested in either
liking or even disliking this guy
right now i still don't quite know how
to feel about him i'm just so
neutral i guess i did like the way he
was brought down with some cool teamwork
and determination and also after that
aster gets both a rock
and bird the rock is apparently
important i don't know why
i imagine i will soon enough i really
like the bird though and i wonder if
there's something more to that because
earlier on in the arc there was a fun
bit of comedy about how certain birds
will attack people if they have low
magic potency so of course all of the
birds immediately flock towards asta
and the same thing has sort of happened
here a mysterious bird has been
attracted to our plucky young anti-mage
and i don't care why it happened
because i love this bird and to conclude
the arc we have a rather enjoyable
epilogue where we get to visit the noble
realm which is
about what you'd expect cobblestone
cobblestone everywhere and everything
and plenty of street clerks as well the
most interesting part
though is the very unexpected reveal of
the wizard
king himself who takes note of asta in a
way that no adult should
ever ever look at a child and while he
does set up either the very next arc or
a meta-narrative i can't help but feel a
bit underwhelmed by his random
appearance
i personally come from the one piece
school of thinking that i like
keeping key figures in the shadows for
long periods of time before an eventual
revelation but in black clover we've now
already revealed the ultimate wizard bro
as well as seeing quite a few of the
squad captains during the entrance exam
like yami william like we saw at least
seven of them
possibly more and i'm just like slow
down
build your house up one brick at a time
save these guys for something more
dramatic because now that we've seen the
wizard king that's great we have a roof
for our house but we don't have any
walls to hold it up that might just be a
me thing though a lot of
things and me things in any case that's
our introduction to black clover it's a
series that really could go one of two
ways to me
either it could exceed all expectations
and develop into an above average shonen
journey which is what i'm hoping for
however it could also land in a very
middling to mediocre place the
genericism does worry me quite a bit but
at the same time you really can't judge
a shonen series by the first handful of
chapters so if you'd like to see me keep
going
you know the thing that it is you need
to do but that pretty much does it for
this blind review of black clover's
introductory arc and what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel for very
maybe black clover goodness delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time